ANIMALS OVER A SIDE COMMENT BY
DONALD TRUMP.
THAT'S THE "ANGLE."
SHIFTING GEARS, WE ARE A YEAR
INTO THE SPECIAL COUNSEL PROBE
AND BOB MUELLER HAS ANOTHER
TARGET.
REUTERS REPORTING HE SUBPOENAED
ROGER STONE'S FORMER SOCIAL
MEDIA SPECIALIST JASON SULLIVAN
TO APPEAR FOREVER A GRAND JURY
TOMORROW.
MUELLER IS INTERESTED IN WHETHER
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN WAS INVOLVED
IN THE WIKI LEAKS RELEASED OF
THOSE EMAILS DURING THE
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
STONE IS A LONG TIME CONFIDANTE
OF PRESIDENT TRUMP AND THE
AUTHOR OF A NEW BOOK:
"STONE'S RULES, HOW TO WIN IN
BUSINESS."
HE JOINS US EXCLUSIVELY.
CONGRATS ON THE BOOK.
WE HAVE SOME RULES WE PULLED
OUT.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION TO NOW?
WE ARE NOW INTO YEAR 2 OF THIS
INVESTIGATION OFFICIALLY TODAY.
THEY ARE BRINGING IN THE GUY WHO
WORKED FOR YOU ON TWITTER AND
SOCIAL MEDIA TRENDING.
WHAT IS GOING ON?
>> AT THIS POINT I DON'T KNOW IF
I AM A PERSON OF INTEREST OR
JUST AN INTERESTING PERSON.
>> Laura: [LAUGHING].
>> IT'S CLEAR NOT ONLY HAS
MR. MUELLER SUBPOENAED A
PART-TIME CONSULTANT WHO WORKED
FOR ME FOR 3 MONTHS, HE DROPPED
SUBPOENAS ON OTHER YOUNG PEOPLE
THAT WORKED FOR ME.
THE FAKE NEWS INSISTS I MUST
HAVE KNOWN IN ADVANCE ABOUT THE
HACKING OF THE DNC -- I DON'T
THINK THAT HAPPENED AT ALL,
NEVER MIND BY THE RUSSIANS.
I MUST HAVE HAD ADVANCED NOTICE
OF THE WIKI LEAKS DNC
DISCLOSURES.
THAT'S IS OF COURSE FALSE.
IT'S NOT PLEASANT TO HAVE A
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR IN YOUR
EMAILS AND YOUR TEXT MESSAGES
AND PHONE CALLS AND HE WAS VERY
CLEARLY IN MINE.
IT'S A VIOLATION OF MY 4TH
AMENDMENT RIGHTS.
THERE IS NO PROBABLE CAUSE HERE.
JULIAN ASSANGE SAID ROGER STONE
DID NOT SAY ANYTHING ON TWITTER
THEY WOULD SAY ON MY OWN TWITTER
FEET.
>> Laura: YOU SAID TRUST ME, IT
WILL BE SOON BE PODESTA'S TIME
IN THE BARREL AND CROOKED
HILLARY.
>> THAT'S A MISQUOTE.
I SAID IT WILL SOON BE THE
PODESTA'S TIME IN THE BAYLOR.
-- BARREL.
I AM REFERRING TO JOHN AND TONY
BECAUSE APRIL OF 2016, THEIR
SHADY RUSSIAN BUSINESS DEALS
WERE EXPOSED.
I NEVER PREDICTED THE HACKING OF
JOHN PODESTA'S EMAIL.
I SAID THE PODESTAS, BUT THAT'S
OMITTED FROM EVERY REPORTER AND
FROM THE FINAL HOUSE COMMITTEE.
IT REFERS TO TWO PEOPLE.
JOHN AND TONY.
>> Laura: YOUR OLD FRIEND ADAM
SHIFT SAID YOU DENY EVERYTHING
SO YOU NEED SUBPOENAS FOR YOUR
TWEETS.
>> WHAT WE OUGHT TO DO IS
SUBPOENA TWITTER FOR DIRECT
MESSAGES THAT WENT TO THESE
PARTICULAR HANDLES OR CAME FROM
ROGER STONE SOWE DON'T HAVE
ACCEPT AND RELY UPON THE WORD OF
ROGER STONE.
I THINK THAT'S A HAZARDOUS THING
TO DO.
ONE THING ROGER STONE AND THE
PRESIDENT HAVE IN COMMON IS A
PHILOSOPHY THAT YOU DENY
EVERYTHING.
THAT ONLY SUCKERS AND LOSERS
ADMIT TO ANYTHING.
IF YOU DENY, IT DID NOT HAPPEN.
>> I TESTIFIED FULLY AND
TRUTHFULLY TO THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE AND
TURNED OVER THE WIKI LEAKS
DIRECT MESSAGE EXCHANGES.
>> Laura: HOW DID YOU GET IN
TOUCH WITH THEM?
>> BY GOING TO DIRECT MESSAGES.
BASED ON THE CONTEXT AND THE
TIMING IT WAS 6 WEEKS AFTER WIKI
LEAK ALL RIGHT PUBLISHED THE DNC
DISCLOSURES.
SO COLLUSION IS IMPOSSIBLE.
THEY ARE BENIGN.
I TURNED THEM OVER TO THE
COMMITTEE.
>> Laura: INTEL HAS IT.
>> THE SENATE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE WILL HAVE IT.
>> Laura: YOU WANTED TO TESTIFY
IN PUBLIC?
>> YES.
BEHIND CLOSED DOORS.
WHY IS THAT?
>> NOW THE HOUSE DEMOCRATS
COMPLAINED THAT MY TESTIMONY IS
NOT PUBLIC AND THEY WANTED IT TO
BE PRIVATE.
I AGREED TO COOPERATE WITH THE
SENATE JUDICIARY AND
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE.
I WOULD LIKE MY TESTIMONY TO BE
IN PUBLIC.
I WILL TURN OVER THESE SAME
DOCUMENTS AND THEY ARE COMPLETE.
>> Laura: GEORGE STEPHANOPOULOS
HAD YOUR OLD COLLEAGUE ON.
>> MICHAEL WHO WORKED ON THE
CAMPAIGN MET WITH MUELLER'S TEAM
THIS WEEK.
HE SAID THEY ASKED A LOT OF
QUESTIONS ABOUT COLLUSION AND HE
WAS CONCERNED ABOUT ROGER STONE
AND OTHERS.
>> Laura: VERY CONCERNED WELL
MANAFORT, STONE AND OTHERS.
>> CNBC AND MSNBC THE PARTISAN
HACK INSISTS THAT MUELLER IS
FOCUSSING ON MY LONG
RELATIONSHIP WITH RICK GATES.
I DIDN'T MEET HIM UNTIL 2016.
I HAVE NEVER BEEN ALONE WITH
HIM.
THERE WAS ONE DINNER.
CAPITO WAS THERE AND STEVE IS
THERE.
MANAFORT IS SUPPOSED TO JOIN US.
AT THE LAST-MINUTE GATE SHOWS UP
IN HIS STEAD.
SHOWING UP LATE AND LEAVING
EARLY.
NO DISCUSSION OF WIKI LEAKS OR
JULIAN ASSANGE.
WE DIDN'T WORK TOGETHER 30 YEARS
AGO.
HE WAS NOT THERE.
THAT'S A FALSEHOOD.
>> Laura: AND THE NUNBERG
COMMENT THAT HE MADE.
HE SHOWED UP ON SOME SHOWS.
THIS IS WHAT YOU SAID ABOUT
JULIAN ASSANGE.
>> THE MINUTE HE TOLD HE MET
WITH JULIAN ASSANGE I ASSUMED HE
WAS LYING.
IT'S SOMETHING ROGER DOES.
IT'S A STONE RULE.
A TRUMP TACTIC TO TAKE CREDIT.
>> SOMETHING HE DOES, ROGER
STONE LIES TO PEOPLE LIKE YOU
HIS MENTEE?
>> YES, I CALL IT EXAGGERATION.
>> WHEN YOU WORK WITH SAM
NUNBERG, SOMETIMES HE WOULD CALL
YOU 40 TIMES A DAY.
>> Laura: THAT'S CALLED
STALKING.
>> ONE FRIDAY LATE IN THE
AFTERNOON WHEN I WANTED TO GET
HIM OFF THE PHONE.
MY WIFE SAID DINNER IS READY AND
SAM KEPT SAYING ONE MORE THING.
DO YOU HAVE ANY PLANS FOR THE
WEEKEND?
YES I AM GOING TO FLY TO LONDON
AND HAVE DINNER WITH JULIAN
ASSANGE.
IT'S SHTICK.
IT'S A JOKE.
>> Laura: ON THE "ANGLE" WE TALK
ABOUT THINGS TAKEN OUT OF
CONTEXT AND BLASTED OUT TO SMEAR
PEOPLE.
>> I MILKED THE JOKE IN AN
EMAIL.
I PROVED I WAS IN LOS ANGELES.
I EVEN PRODUCED A RECEIPT FROM A
DELI IN SANTA MONICA.
MY PASSPORT, CUSTOM'S RECORDS
AND AIRLINES.
>> Laura: YOU HAVE NEVER BEEN TO
RUSSIA?
>> I WAS NOT IN LONDON AND I
NEVER MET OR SPOKE WITH JULIAN
ASSANGE.
>> Laura: STONE'S RULES FROM
YOUR BOOK, WHICH I LOVE.
MY FAVORITE PART OF STONE'S
RULES.
HIT FROM EVERY ANGLE.
OPEN MULTIPLE FRONTS ON YOUR
ENEMY.
THE ENEMY MUST BE CONFUSED AND
FEEL DESIEGED ON EVERY SIDE.
THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE DOING TO
DONALD TRUMP?
>> THEY ARE TRYING TO DO.
EVERYTHING THE PRESIDENT NEEDS
TO DO TO SURVIVE IS IN THIS
BOOK.
THIS RULE:
ATTACK AND ATTACK AND DON'T
DEFEND.
I LOVE IT WHEN HE CALLS OUT THE
FAKE NEWS MEDIA AND WHEN HE
EXPOSES WHAT IS THE GREATEST
POLITICAL SCANDAL IN AMERICAN
HISTORY.
THE USE OF A PHONEY DOSSIER TO
RATIONALIZE THE SURVEILLANCE BY
THE STATE TO SPY ON THE
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE FOR